c'est le trac dans la cour de cette
école du centre-ville daudet ça il y a
des enfants réticents
ont dormi il y a des timides la
complicité des retrouvailles
et la course pour arriver avant la
cloche éléphants
car c'est la coutume en ukraine pour les
enfants célébrer la rentrée vêtus de
leurs plus jolies vêtements bouquet de
fleurs à la mer a dit tout haut on dit
tu as bâton
après deux ans de confinement kfw mais
surtout six mois de guerre terrifiante
franchir les portes une école est à la
fois une délivrance est un geste de
courage
[Musique]
d'ailleurs la première activité prévue
ce matin avant même d'ouvrir un seul
livre c'est d'amener les élèves dans les
sous sols où nous devrons courir chaque
jour quand les sirènes annonce une
menace
aussi stressant que cela puisse paraître
ces petits compte parmi les plus
privilégiés entre un car seules les
écoles qui ont un abri adéquat ont reçu
le feu vert du gouvernement pour
accueillir des élèves en personne moins
de 40% des établissements du pays ont
passé le test à odessa c'est seulement
10 % c'est-à-dire 33 écoles
c'est donc en ligne et de la maison que
des millions de petits ukrainiens ont
repris les cours aujourd'hui souvent
dans des conditions difficiles car la
guerre a exacerbé le sort des familles
qui vivaient déjà dans la précarité
chez les smirnova la rentrée se fait
sans paillettes ni ballon les parents
n'ont même pas les moyens d'acheter un
ordinateur usagé être brutaux et fort
ce sera un cauchemar d'il ya parce que
nous n'avons aucun soutien informel
stone boutiste yannick les trois enfants
vont se partager ce petit téléphone
intelligent pour suivre leurs cours à
distance ioulia indique le gouvernement
ne peut pas les aider pour l'instant
nicolas rêve est de revoir ses amis et
ses profs mais il devra se contenter du
petit bureau installé dans leur modeste
salon sert aussi de chambre à coucher
aux parents les studieux mais dit qu'il
sera soldats quand il sera grand pour
défendre son pays y'a voyenne
vos deux échecs
il ya aura tout fait pour les protéger
du stress km la guerre mais ils en
paient quand même le prix à leur façon
les autorités en ont mal au ventre au
les narbonnais beach qui la cheffe du
département d'éducation de death a dit
qu'elle attend des nouvelles du soutien
de l'unicef pour équiper les enfants
et qui éduque l'agent se mobilisent mais
ça prend beaucoup de temps car pour
l'instant la priorité c'est de
construire des abris anti bon et c'est
un véritable marathon
ce lycée est un des trois établissements
scolaires de dessin ou les travaux on
commence
une tâche macabre en 2022 qui dépasse
l'entendement
on n'a jamais pensé sans jamais jamais
jamais
c'est bien difficile de comprendre
les deux peuples
voisins
les deux peuples qui parlent presque la
même langue
et comme ça
il faudra des mois pour adapter la
ventilation électricité
de toute façon les parents ont peur le
directeur
99%
des paroles de nous là on dit oui
au grain
c'est l'enquêté qui n'en portent au
quotidien et se lit sur les visages des
parents ce sentiment d'impuissance mais
ce besoin urgent de protéger leur
innocence
il cite à malte rspo radio-canada au
dessin